le redécoupage de la carte électorale
créé une certaine confusion si loin
qu'on peut dire à dieppe au nouveau
brunswick
la ville est littéralement scindée en
deux et comme l'a constaté mon collègue
pierre alexandre bolduc ce nouvelles
frontières politiques mènent une
véritable guerre de pancartes la guerre
du meilleur emplacement pour
l'installation des pancartes électorales
et bien commencé dans le sud est du
nouveau brunswick avec le redécoupage de
la carte électorale la ville de dieppe
est désormais divisé en deux d'un côté
il y à la circonscription de moncton
dieppe riverview et de l'autre celle de
beauséjour
le problème c'est que certains candidats
n'hésitent pas à s'afficher d'un côté
comme de l'autre et pour certains
électeurs difficile de s'y retrouver
moshe du seco qui sonne la papetière
actuelle je pense que ça s'apprend de
type à confusion
si on arrive de métier par captivait où
ils veulent sauf que
j'ai cinq enfants bien on arrivait de
shediac il dit quand je vois ça les deux
concourent ensemble
ce chien confusion oui le député libéral
sortant beauséjour dominic leblanc est
le candidat de la circonscription
voisine ginette petits pâtés leur
affaire campagne jeu parfois à la
confusion
hélène boudreau une candidate du npd a
choisi de gérer les choses autrement
elle a carrément demandé à son collègue
et voisin de respecter les frontières
c'est que certains endroits sont plus
convoités que d'autres cantons normale
en acadie on règle nos problèmes
amicalement
on espère que nos collègues et nos
opposants ce de la mer auteurs il n'y a
rien dans la loi électorale qui interdit
aux candidats de s'afficher dans une
autre circonscription que la leur c'est
donc la loi du plus rapide qui détermine
qu'un et à quel endroit chacun peut
installer ses parcs